el número de palacios que construyó
Sadam husein su ciudad es un ejemplo de
los beneficios que recibió la gente de
la ciudad y no solamente de su tribu
durante su gobierno que tenían puestos
en todas las instituciones del país
luego de la invasión y cuando empezaron
a gobernar los partidos de mayoría Chita
y empezaron ese proceso de
diversificación del país de sacar a los
gentes cercanas
aquí en ciudades como eclipse sintieron
amenazados y sintieron que estaban
haciendo con ellos una revancha sin duda
la gente ha sufrido muchas familias han
sido destruidas en esta provincia de
Salem cuando Isis la ocupó se
destruyeron muchas personas muchas casas
muchas madres perdieron a sus hijos y
familias de hecho los residentes han
sufrido mucho porque Sadam era hijo de
la ciudad mucha gente ha pagado las
consecuencias incluso sin haber estado
relacionado con él estos carteles
recogen las fotos de solo algunos de los
1700 jóvenes que eran entrenados un
campo militar en las cercanías de ti
crit cuando Isis tomó el control de al
menos del 40 por ciento de Irak esta
organización ordenó al asesinato de cada
uno de ellos muchos fueron tirados uno a
uno al río y otros enterrados en fosas
comunes en lo que habían sido esos
Palacios de la dictador Sadam hussein
aquí los remanentes del partido vas y
los terroristas de Isis eran la misma
cara de la moneda ellos hicieron esto en
la ciudad de saddán para vengarlo
ambos tuvieron la oportunidad de
trabajar juntos en estos Palacios junto
al río y cometer esta masacre
Lo que sucede es uno de los grandes
retos que tiene Irak por delante en las
pmf que también conocidas como hashtag
Xavi que lideraron la batalla contra el
estado islámico una vez esta batalla
terminó estas milicias muchas de ellas
prohiranías tienen presencia en estas
ciudades sunitas
Claro que al comienzo hubo
preocupaciones y temores dentro de ambos
lados
los combatientes que participaron en la
liberación y los residentes de la ciudad
pero esos temores han ido desapareciendo
ambos han descubierto que los rumores
que corrían sobre ambos lados que eran
agresivos o que cometían actos violentos
eran equivocados